voici stv
c
alors steve hill le look voilà le luxe
tv les lentilles opaline des nantis
autre signe particulier de stevie grain
de beauté sous le bras gauche
donc oui c'est ça
alors il y en a un autre il ya un
deuxième candidat rhdp sur ma verges au
sol
tu t'en sors bien sûr là peut être sur
la [ __ ] voix est ce que steve est ce que
vous vous suit c'est toujours le pouce
oh oui oui c'est sont tous issus sont
polis avec vous marrer avec qui il était
en fait il est avec son pouce valable et
alors bourrique et vous lave n'est plus
là votre peluche la sepa il est chez moi
rocco dans la new wave bomb est un des
rares lofteurs est devenu vraiment star
je suis pas une star ou là aussi
merci mais non c'est vraiment pas le cas
même si vous prenez soin d'expliquer la
différence qu'il ya entre la notoriété
la célébrité vous êtes une star si c'est
évident tout le monde là tout le monde
l'a vu et puis ça va durer ben ça risque
de durer
mais ça reste dur a excellé en tout cas
il ya du fond bah je sais pas si il fait
vachement attention à son image c'est
vrai on fait pas de trucs bas de gamme
et on vous voit plus souvent avec jean
paul gaultier qu'en tournée dans les
discothèques c'est vrai c'est vrai j'ai
rarement en discothèque
voilà est votre livre est d'ailleurs
assez assez haut de gamme l'album photo
qui s'appelle harvey sait jamais
alors ok pas sévir gars tu vas voir
attention tu fais pas là que pour ma
promo est bon on a un truc c'est pas les
gars ici c'est sans toi
sur soi que vous ne ferez pas
l'équipement alors en voilà ce qui va se
passer
magnéto et voilà comment ça
c'est truqué quand même quand vous serez
pas là je suis déçu par ces thèmes et
voilà bien alors vous voulez regarder le
formidable sadi rené voilà
hu
c'est un très beau petit vie magnifique
la rondelle en quinconce non
lisez le bouquin moi je suis là t'as vu
c'est intéressant
stevie donc c'est pas une autobiographie
en matière et j'ai remarqué ça ouais
c'est ça ton ouvrage si bien léché alors
c'est pas une autobiographie comme loana
c'est un album photos où vous avez
réalisé cinq voeux voilà alors le
premier veut c'était de partir en
vacances en famille ouais parce que
j'étais jamais parti en vacances avec ma
maman et ma soeur là c'est le premier
veut ensuite mis à manhattan vous
promener dans manhattan d'ailleurs on
voit bien la fin regard de laurent les
photos on voit les twin towers ont été
grisé voilà alors là c'est ce genre en
un hommage aux victimes des attentats
on cite souvent un hommage on est juste
énorme pour eux si c'est pas grand chose
qui me rend pas compte ils sont dans la
merde sont terrorisés que le fait que je
fasse ça pour ça si j'avais su ça avant
ensuite vous aurez vous veniez à malibu
et dîner dans un restaurant à bel air
qui était un quartier de los angeles à
côté de beverly hills la voile en
bretagne la vapeur est alors le dernier
voeu c'était un secret vous avez voulu
revoir la colonne est mal à vis du mans
où vous étiez quand vous étiez petit
alors vous allez là-bas quand j'étais
petit à audierne voilà et j'y suis
retournée avec le député maire du mans
et alors là tous ces voyages de l'été de
styles y sont désormais dans cet album
il ya beaucoup d'émotions j'ai vu trois
quatre photos chez au bord des larmes
sècheront comme un arrêt c'est chaud
bon c'est pas chier soufflage
voila voila et soufflage
alors je vais vous montrer la photo ou
stevie en victoire quinquin regarder
l'expression l album bel album laisse le
reste en tout les deux steve est oui
laisse-le tomber bon alors donc il ya le
bouquin déjà à une première chose
ensuite la télévision feng steevy sur
sur fun qui vit à vous parler de musique
vous parler de mode
vous parlez de people et vous donner des
conseils c'est bien 850 français
accessible
donc vous êtes sur fun tv comme on l'a
dit en radio avec laurent ruquier sur
europe 1 s'est souvent l'après midi et
puis voilà pile reste du temps vous
passez votre vie et que les [ __ ] ou
enfin le petit truc pour une petit
projet on va savoir qui se cache
derrière cette image
[Applaudissements]
stevie c'est votre vrai prénom c'est bon
on va prénom steevy boulay boulet avec
isabelle d'accord vous êtes né à lille
en 1981 et trois semaines plus tard vous
partiez pour le mans oui on stoppe bain
avec ma maman avec sa maman alors
apparaître votre maman justement votre
maman vous avez quand elle avait 19 ans
elle s'appelle zohra elle a eu une
enfance assez difficile
elle a été placée la dass parce que
c'est un enfant battu par sa mère est le
premier homme qu'elle a rencontré
c'était votre père on va là et elle
s'est retrouvée enceinte elle couche
avec lui elle surtout vincent vallat
c'est des choses qui arrivent
magnéto
et je n'en pleure ensemble est champion
ensemble quand elle découvre sa
grossesse lui demande d'avorter mais
elle ne veut pas vers l'infused avorter
elle devait partir en angleterre elle
n'a pas voulu partir en angleterre l'a
voulu garder son enfant
voilà heureusement qu'est ce qu'on
ferait sans lui et après la naissance
votre père décide finalement de faire
face et de l'épousé
voilà mais malheureusement quand arrive
le deuxième enfant aurélie votre petite
soeur
le couple se sépare parce qu'ils
battaient votre mère est une scène comme
ça un jour je parle avec matin jeudi
mais j'ai une scène qui est dans ma tête
et qui me qui m'insupporte en fait c'est
j'étais petit je devais avoir trois ans
mais c'est une scène qui m'a marqué mais
jusqu'à la fin de mes jours
ma mère était enceinte je sais pas
c'était c'était assez je devais être sur
ces huit mois et je me souviens d'une
scène j'étais gamin j'étais avec ma
tante je tenais la main ma tante et mon
père ils arrivent ils avaient un peu
trop bu et il dit à ma mère va chercher
une bassine à ma mère a dit nantes a été
capable de boire tu es capable d'aller
chercher une bassine à ma mère elle
monte escalier il a pris ma mère ma mère
elle est tombé des escaliers alors
qu'elle était enceinte et je peux vous
dire vous êtes petit garçon et vous
voyez ça eva gens me dire que ça vous
reste dans lequel voilà c'était une
scène tant d'autres voilà dans votre
mère est obligé de faire des ménages
pour vous élevez parce qu'elle n'a pas
beaucoup d'argent voilà
et vous dites que quand vous étiez
petits dés fois la maison il y avait
deux assiettes pour 3 voilà alors ça
c'est aussi le 17 juillet ma maman qu'il
faisait à manger bon bah on n'avait pas
les moyens manger souvent du lait avec
du pain on a misé sur la grille et et
voilà et il y avait souvent deux
assiettes et au lieu de trois parce que
ma mère va nous regarder manger elle
prépare à manger en entend moins fait
autre chose à repasser mais c'est vrai
que à chaque fois se voir dans le passé
il ya toujours deux assiettes sur cette
maudite table alors votre père il vous a
pas donné de nouvelles jusqu'à ce que
vous sortiez du loft et à la sortie du
loft votre père vous dis j'aurais pu
être dur avec toi mais regarde où tu en
es comme si la sévérité qu'il avait eu à
votre égard et est pour quoi que ce soit
en direct
loft 1 ces enfants moi je sois pas la
vie comme ça parce qu' un enfant ça a
besoin de son père ouais voilà alors
quand vous étiez enfant vous n'avez pas
de vocation précise via des vétérinaires
celui-là est vite et risque existe
ensuite à la télé et présenter la météo
que ça vous et pourquoi pas mais vous
étiez persuadé que vous seriez star
quand vous seriez grand mais je sais ce
que j'ai toujours dit à ma mère un jour
maman je serai à la télé et donc j'ai
décidé de faire des études dans
l'audiovisuel j'ai obtenu mon diplôme un
en audiovisuel et voila voila puis après
il ya le loft on a suffisamment parlé
la télévision a pas recommencer ce soir
vous êtes sorti le 24 mai et puis voilà
que vous êtes parti en vacances est le
résultat de ces vacances c'est dans cet
album on va garder ce livre qui restera
je pense parce que c'est un bel ouvrage
dit alors à paris la marge est la bonne
vie vous fréquentez les vip et puis
surtout on peut l'aider si quand même et
puis surtout avec marie myriam
dans dix ans vous voyez caser avec trois
enfants
j'aimerais ah bon si j'ai une petite
fille j'appelle kenza c'est un petit
garçon j'appelle kevin et si j'ai une
petite fille j'appellerai azilal et hop
parce que là attention il ya un gros
scoop gros gros scoop qui arrive là gros
scoop à stevie n'est pas homo alors
attendez moi je n'ai jamais parlé de ma
vie privée que je sois au mot que je
souhaitais que ce soit hétérosexuel que
soit mono sexuelle ça ne regarde
personne
non non j'ai déclaré dans le journal je
ne suis pas homo vous avez déclaré oui
c'est vrai j'ai participé à la gay pride
avec mes cousins franck c'est exact
c'est raconter d'histoires en main mon
garçon c'est exact
m
à
oh
merci les enfants c'est vrai c'est vrai
que vous avez participé à la gay pride
avec votre cousin français lui est
homosexuel mais vous ne l'êtes pas c'est
vous qui avez dit ça j'en sais rien et
après tout réellement longtemps que
j'avais pas eu une aventure sexuelle
bah oui j'ai vraiment terminée par
croire que je suis mounaud sexuelle oui
j'aime la loi n'a rien depuis jean
edouard non plus n'a rien d'un alambic
excusez moi savons nous mettrons tout ça
sortira il beaucoup attendant ça prend
quatre heures annoncés non vous ne
diriez un mois déjà bombe un an
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas des plus
faciles parce que moi la personne je
parle pour moi par le pont des autres
lofteurs le matin je me lève lundi m6
mardi m6 mercredi et à la gaule wifi -
csn je me prends leucémie
magnéto serge et maintenant pour lancer
petit alors moi je vais dire quand même
le rêve de 2stv que vous l'avez déclaré
en tous les cas dans la presse c'est une
fille avec leur garçon tu veux en même
temps le mans une fille avec des bosses
un bien formés avec ça je suis friand
des belles poitrines belle poitrine des
cheveux longs cheveux loin et ouverte à
tous est ouverte à tous ouverte à tous
voilà bien si vous sentez concerné vous
pouvez toujours envoyer un email
sur le site de france 2 tout le monde en
parle voilà il y aurait eu une aventure
possible avec l'or dans leurs
franchement il ya un moment où oui
j'aurais vraiment pu faire l'amour avec
l'or mais mais il ya deux choses
les pressions ces cas les caméras parce
qu'avec aïcha séparez vous sortez du
lobe de là l'hôtel accueille chassaing
atria
s'ils le font a capella
merci bon alors aïcha qu'est ce qui se
passe avec aïcha ouachin aïcha c'est sa
meilleure amie
c'est une amie d'enfance mais à l'époque
où il était amoureux d'elle elle était
avec un autre mec
donc il ne pouvait rien faire c'est vrai
c'est vrai que les plus jeunes à faire
avec aïcha donc il sort du loft il va à
l'hôtel avec aïcha la première nuit
après le loft rien du tout
nancy mais loana l'avait déjà eu jean
edouard jamais derrière quelqu'un t'a
entendu ça ça c'est bon à savoir
c'est une info qui veulent pas aller
dans la crise car d'où l'importance des
peluches
quand tu l'achètes tu es sûr que les
notes
enfin vous savez ce que je pense moi je
vais dire ce que je pense je pense que
vous avez été traumatisée oui par la
perte de votre chatte grise ou non mais
ça c'est aussi ça on rigole mais jamais
dire que ce jour là
olhain ouais quand tu perds ta chatte
et là encore subi en l'honneur de green
zone
nous allons faire une interview chatte
[Applaudissements]
je vous hais
mais il te déteste aussi attention
interview chatte vous êtes prêt e s
est ce qu'une chatte aime être caressé
oui combien de bébés peut avoir une
chatte 5
combien de temps dure la relation
sexuelle chez la chatte 20 minutes
non non de une à deux minutes ah ouais
ouais
ma chatte amérique beaucoup plus
longtemps avant ça les tinner pourquoi
est ce qu'on ne l'avait jamais une
chatte la mine jal avait donc j'ai pas
avant la chatte se lèchent avec sa
langue humide et rappeuse ouais c'est
bizarre parce que grease une enfin quand
même lui n'a pas ce que c'est le
deuxième chapeau elle rentre enfin les
deux contre un avec moi dans la salle de
bains un bien alors dernière question de
votre interview chatte steevy comment
reconnaît-on une vieille chatte à la
moule qui bâille
suivi par stevie est là messieurs
donc comme sexe pour vous depuis un an
vous avez vous rattraper j'espère non il
va se faire après depuis jean et noir
bah ouais ben apparemment on va en
parler tout de suite voici le vin
taiana les deux plus beaux lofteurs avec
nous ce soir
alonso ont fait connaissance lors de la
sortie de votre livre miettes dans une
interview lors d'une émission de
télévision qui s'appelle ça s'en va et
ça revient d'ailleurs je dois dire à mes
amitiés spectateurs que lundi soir in
avec les inconnus qui est pas piquée des
hannetons en à raconter votre vie votre
enfance douloureuse et on m'a beaucoup
reproché ma gentillesse avec vous j'ai
vu c'est fou quand même hein alors j'en
profite pour dire que je regrette pas du
tout ma gentillesse avec loana j'ai
beaucoup de compassion pour votre
histoire et je maintiens tout ce que
j'ai dit ce soir là tous les faits sur
les ce sera à refaire je referais
exactement la même chose
merci beaucoup voilà je pense que ce
sont des gens comme vous qui statuez en
tous les cas alors il s'est bien vendu
votre livre très bien oui combien peu à
peu près cent mille exemples ici
beaucoup dit non non c'est bien donc
l'éditeur a récupéré la valoir d'un
million de francs qui vous avez versé
oui en principe on est content et oui
comment votre mère très très bien il n'y
a pas longtemps
yvette va bien il va de batteries parce
que toute ma famille c'est vrai votre
père départ bull n'ont toujours pas bien
marché donc un coup de fil ça va
s'arranger là tu sais c'est parce qu'ils
ont les faire en ce moment mouais c'est
le poème de pertes ou les deux là
là on a un peu la veille et enfin la
même et un niveau famille où on n'a pas
eu beaucoup de chance je suis
oui quand vous êtes venue dans
l'émission beaucoup de gens étaient
choqués par le fait que vous soyez pas
retourner voir votre fille mindy
immédiatement après le loft
est-ce que depuis vous étalez non je
parte on avait remarqué par quand je
suis en contact et je sais qu'elle va
très très très bien non non non vous
voulez pas la voir il fallait vraiment
pas qu'on sache où aller mais bientôt ça
ça va s'arranger bien alors ça ça va
bien maintenant avec l'argent du loft
vous achetez un trois pièces à paris oui
vous emménagez en décembre ni décembre
je le dis à nos amis je voulait pendre
la crémaillère 6
ou dans le xvième médocaine rue de la
pompe visé dans le mille un parent c'est
à beaucoup de presse
ouais des problèmes avec la presse
johanna non non non non moins bien sûr
je pense pas qu'ils aient vraiment ma
tient en fait à trouver un scandale
parce que jusqu'à l'âge reste entrevue
disais je suis une nymphomane quand je
suis amoureuse mais quand vous n'êtes
pas amoureux souvent toute façon ça fait
pas à conséquence je pense qu'en mer on
l'est tous en fait qu'entendre tomber ça
va faire beaucoup mais recevant les
membres
quand on rencontre quelqu'un quand même
bien sûr en revanche c'est un très bon
article dans le magazine photo est un
magazine très prestigieux après mondino
et bettina rheims
ce coup ci c'est de marcher leye qui
vous a fait des photos seins à new york
alors demarchelier qui était un grand
photographe vous a demandé de poser nue
loana sans déconner me regarde ce que
j'aime a fait pour lui donc c'est ça
vous avez refusé de le faire c'est
refuser mais de la faire j'ai pas non ça
ça ne me plaît pas je pense pas que
j'aurais été à l'aise donc c'est pas la
peine il mais là pas raciste et il m'a
proposé j'ai dit que je me sentirai
palaysi l'aller ce qu'on voulait
préserver votre intimité une certaine
petite partie mais bien pour pour votre
homme
pour madame je vais vous allez bientôt
rencontrer mais la sptr on verra bien
bon juste que la première fois que vous
faites l'amour avec quelqu'un dit obligé
d'être dans le noir très pudique loi nâ
1 c'est vrai oui un petit peu ma chez
palm
et ça complètement dans l'est la
première fois c'est vrai que dans là
vous étiez en string et topless assez
souvent non non je veux dire quand on se
changeait forcément un passé un stade où
on est tous le monde pour changer ça
vous gênez pas dans le lot mais j'étais
pas là entre rentrer comme ça ça sera
doux j'étais tout nu et bien sûr mais
bon quand je me déshabille et je me
déshabiller sur mon lit loana on va
parler de votre on va parler de votre
calendrier
ce qui vient qu'un
non attendez baffie autre chose ma fille
à autre chose c'est sa manière déloyale
est sérieuse grande vie alors racontez
nous ce calendrier loana alors le
calendrier loana ça a été une
proposition qui m'a été fait et
ambitions ou leurs maîtres les l'émoi
dans l'ordre alors comment et quand même
assez logique un parti d'idées quand
comment non mais on m'a proposé de faire
un calendrier est ce que la chose que
j'ai trouvé très belle et je pars c'est
bien photo ce sont de belles photos mais
pudique ou pas bah oui
et quand le tourbillon s'arrête quand
vient le soir seul avec son chien necker
mais qu'est ce qui s'appelle n'est
qu'après un nom d'hôpital pour un chien
mais je savais pas à l'époque c'était le
chien de matin quand j'étais tout petit
c'est énorme ce qui m'impressionnait et
j'ai voulu en mettre leur match le
prénom sont donc voilà seul le soin avec
son chien mesquer vous redevenez la
loana d'avant mais je pense bien si
c'est elle qui commande une grosse pizza
temps en temps j'aime bien faire foi
mais bien sûr vous êtes seul le soir
chez vous et qu'il grosse pizza et de
vidéos ça n'arrive pas tout le temps
mais j'aime bien oui c'est une grosse
pizza et regarder quelques films aussi
je suis tout seul chez moi le soir avec
les fours auspices
c'est ridicule ça voilà donc lohan un
coeur à prendre
et encore brown dès maintenant à tous
genres voilà pour énoncer un appel non
non non non mais c'est quoi tes centres
d'intérêts thème bien courir nu au
ralenti sur la plage n'ont pas trop de
quoi il ya des promenades en forêt le
cinéma les pizzas voilà voilà
à ce petit jeu c'est important pour les
gens vous le faites si bien ouais j'ai
pas suivi parce que j'ai tout le monde
cherchait un mec faut qu'il est méchant
c'est quoi me dit voter du tout un
acteur qu'on voit un peu à quoi ça
ressemble à un acteur comme ça bruce
willis
le pire est à venir loana interview
expliqué à ma fille
loana si votre petite fille qui parle
par ma bouche comme dans l'exorciste dit
maman il est où papa n'a pas n'a pas
voulu de toi dis maman c'est qu'ils
jean-edouard je te montre america 7 qui
comprend 10 maman tu m'aimes bien suivi
oui j'aime beaucoup et baffie tulle aime
bien jusque là ça va on verra plus tard
et hardy sont très sains allumeuse
dis maman comment on fait les bébés
spectre un petit peu plus tard quand on
a grandi
ah bon tu m'expliqueras louana dis maman
pourquoi le monsieur qui vient des fois
la maison il tombera sur la bouche
ah parce que parce qu'il aime beaucoup
pourquoi ne voit plus tout le temps à la
télé parce que je préfère m'occuper de
toi m'a dit maman
le monsieur qui était embrasse tout le
temps sur la bouche il a fait la même
chose à la baby sitter sébine dit là bas
je dis maman on va rester toujours
ensemble maintenant oui bien sûr
je t'aime c'est une chanson spécialement
pour moi
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de la
latitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux